liebe zuschauer ich habe eine sehr
wichtige ankündigung für euch denn er
ist ihr da donald trump
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja das ist richtig trump ist wieder in
den nachrichten und warum nur wegen den
hier trump verklagt twitter google und
facebook wegen angeblicher zensur wie
ihr wisst haben alle großen
internetplattformen nach der erstürmung
des kapitols alle accounts von donald
trump gesperrt
[Musik]
warum nun sie argumentiert sonst hätte
seine anhänger zuvor aufgelöst mit
anderen worten sie haben ihn nicht
beschuldigt den angriff irgendwie
organisiert zu haben aber sie
beschuldigten ihn ein klima des hasses
geschaffen zu haben welches den angriff
dann provozierte und schon ist das feld
eröffnet für eine hitzige und sehr
ernste debatte inwieweit sprechende über
zensur und ich weiß was viele denken
facebook twitter und youtube sind doch
privatunternehmen und können bei sich
alle regeln machen die sie wollen aber
so einfach ist das nun mal nicht das
problem ist dass diese drei plattformen
ein oligopol für online-inhalte haben
das heißt wenn youtube einen kanal
abschaltet ist es sehr schwierig fast
unmöglich für diesen kanal eine andere
ähnliche plattform zu finden von der aus
er seine zuschauer noch erreichen kann
aber warte ein moment denn wir reden
hier nicht nur darüber welche laune
gerade die großen tech unternehmen haben
denn eigentlich sitzen twitter facebook
und google zwischen zwei stühlen auf der
einen seite prangern trump und viele
andere sie an weil sie das recht auf
freie meinungsäusserung verletzten aber
auf der anderen seite setzten viele
regierungen sind unter druck alles zu
entfernen was als schädliche inhalte
gewertet werden könnte also aufgepasst
facebook und youtube sehen sich mit
neuen harten gesetzen zu extremistischen
und expliziten videos konfrontiert
europa schlägt neue regeln und bußgelder
forum social media firmen zu zwingen
online-videos zu bekämpfen um die reine
vorstellung zu geben einige dieser
gesetze sehen geldstrafen von bis zu 50
millionen euro vor die frage ist ob es
sich wirklich um zensur handelt und wie
vernünftig es ist von youtube zu
verlangen uns vor schädlichen inhalten
zu schützen heute werden wir diese
fragen beantworten aber lasst uns zuerst
einen blick auf die geschichte werfen
[Musik]
wieviel meinungsfreiheit ist zuviel
meinungsfreiheit im november 2015 wurde
ein spanisches mädchen am madrider
flughafen verhaftet als sie gerade in
die türkei reisen wollte um sich dort
das anzuschließen das unglaublichste an
dieser geschichte ist dass das
betreffende medien nicht einmal in eine
muslimische familie hineingeboren wurde
dieses mädchen wurde durch die
propaganda in den sozialen medien
radikalisiert denn es gab eine zeit vor
nicht allzu vielen jahren als online
absurd einfach war radikal islamische
propaganda videos zu finden es gab sie
sogar auf instagram natürlich gibt es in
fast allen demokratischen ländern
gesetze die terroristische propaganda
verbieten
dh auch wenn die verfassung eines
solchen europäischen landes die
meinungsfreiheit anerkennt gibt es
einige grenzen ein expliziter aufruf zur
gewalt ist eine davon das problem egal
wie viele gesetze es gibt ihre umsetzung
ist immer nur so effektiv und schnell
wie das justizsystem selbst und dieses
ist nun mal viel viel langsamer als das
internet daher ist es sehr schwer zu
verhindern dass jemand eine
terroristische propaganda video erstellt
und dieses dann erstmal viral geht und
millionen von menschen erreicht bevor
die gesetzeshüter einschreiten und es
entfernen lassen das ist nun mal die
andere seite der freiheit die uns das
internet gibt und damals verfügte nur
eine plattform über algorithmen um die
videos rechtzeitig zu erkennen
und ja diese plattformen wie youtube
warum das nur ist nun das ist ein thema
seit anderes video aber die wahrheit ist
dass facebook instagram und twitter sich
keine große mühe gemacht hatten extreme
gruppen wieder es und viele andere daran
zu hindern sich auszutoben dies bot
mehreren europäischen ländern den anlass
neue gesetze zu erlassen mit denen die
plattformen also facebook und twitter
für inhalte die nutzer auf ihnen
veröffentlichen direkt verantwortlich
machen und eines dieser länder wollte
hierbei mal wieder der absolute
klassenprimus seine deutschland
[Musik]
nun so ganz unlogisch ist dies auf den
ersten blick nicht seit dem ende des
zweiten weltkriegs gibt es in
deutschland sehr strenge gesetze um die
redefreiheit von nazis und neonazis
einzuschränken das leugnen des holocaust
zum beispiel kann mit jahrelanger haft
bestraft werden in einigen fällen haben
diese gesetze jedoch situationen wie
dieser geriet wolfenstein in deutschland
aufgrund von nazi-symbolen auch den
verkauf genommen dabei hatte der
hersteller in der deutschen fassung
speziell sowohl alle verfassungswidrigen
sowohl entfernt als auch die
gewaltdarstellung drastisch reduziert
erst ab 2019 hat deutschland die
vollkommene beschlagnahme der deutschen
version des spiels aufgehoben ist jedoch
weiterhin mit einer altersfreigabe ab 18
auf den index belassen anja in
deutschland gibt es eben schon länger
stärkere einschränkungen extremer
inhalte als in anderen ländern und das
macht aus historischer sicht ja durchaus
zu sehen und so ließ sich auch die
deutsche regierung nicht lumpen als sie
im jahr 2017 ihr neues gesetz zur
durchsetzung des rechts in den sozialen
netzwerken und kurz netz.de geht durch
den bundestag gepeitscht nach diesem
gesetz sind youtube facebook und twitter
dazu verpflichtet schädliche inhalte
innerhalb von 24 stunden zu entfernen
nachdem sich von den behörden
benachrichtigt worden wenn sie das nicht
tun müssen sie unter umständen
geldstrafen von bis zu 50 millionen euro
in kauf nehmen das klingt doch alles
super verein nicht wahr da haben die
deutschen mit ihrer gründlichkeit doch
wieder mal alles richtig gemacht oder
oder haben diese querulanten bei der
sozialpolitik etwa auch an diesem
meisterwerk teutonischer gesetzgebungs
kunst etwas auszusetzen nun eher wie
soll ich sagen also was ursprünglich als
mittel gegen terror propaganda lanciert
wurde ist am ende zu einem ganz
eigenständigen monster mutiert
[Musik]
denn genau an diesem tag an dem das
netzwerk durch das gesetz in kraft trat
sperrte twitter den kauf der afg
bundestagsfraktionschefin wer tricks von
storch wegen eines vermeintlich
ausländerfeindlichen betriebs und auch
facebook möchte den gleichen posten mit
verweis auf paragraf 130 des deutschen
strafgesetzbuchs gegen volksverhetzung
aber aufgepasst von storch ist nämlich
selbst juristin und hat laut matthias ja
hallo seines zeichens
rechtswissenschaftler und richter am
oberlandesgericht frankfurt am main den
gezielt so formuliert dass er den
straftatbestand der volksverhetzung eben
nicht erfülle von storch hätte sich ganz
bewusst an der grenze des zulässigen
bedingt diese jedoch nicht überschritten
die staatsanwaltschaft berlin stellte
das ermittlungsverfahren gegen die afg
abgeordnete daher auch eine und twitter
muss den account wieder herstellen denn
es war das netzwerk welches hier gegen
das gesetz verstoßen hatte
wer jedoch denkt twitter hätte damit
seine lektion gelernt liegt total
daneben denn jetzt ging die luft aus
sozialen netzwerke erst richtig los ein
paar tage später erlöste twitter auch
den account des satiremagazins titanic
welches die afg politikerin parodiert
also eindeutig kritisiert hatte und auch
den account eines comedians der ein witz
über die afg gemacht hatte das fazit
wenn du einen twitter konnte deutschland
hast ist es am besten gar nicht über
einwanderer zu sprechen egal ob positiv
oder negativ lautet die botschaft von
facebook und co nun also schenke uns
brav damit daten und aufmerksamkeit
damit werde ich mit werbung bewiesen und
milliarden scheffeln können halte aber
ansonsten gefälligst einen mund wenn es
um themen geht die uns den
werbetreibenden oder gar der regierung
nicht gefallen könnten nur wir reden
hier nicht nur über ein paar extremfälle
um die reine vorstellung zu geben allein
in den ersten sechs monaten des jahres
2009 10 hat youtube mehr als 280 videos
entfernt und youtube ist das einzige
unternehmen das seine le statistik
öffentlich gemacht hat aber auch die
unterschiede zwischen facebook twitter
und youtube werden wir noch zu sprechen
kommen allerdings erst im nächsten video
dieser reihe über zensur in dem wir uns
mit der moderation um zensur von
inhalten post kommentaren und so weiter
auseinandersetzen werden wenn ich dieses
thema also interessiert und du bist
nicht verpassen will sony einfach ganz
schnell diesen kanal und aktiviere auch
die kleine glocke damit du nichts mehr
von uns verpasst aber zurück zum stg
sicher ist dass dieses deutsche gesetz
eine art mensch macht geschaffen hat im
jahr 2020 verabschiedete frankreich ein
weiteres gesetz zur bekämpfung von hass
rede der unterschied ist jedoch das ist
das französische verfassungsgericht zu
fall gebracht hat und hier kommt das
andere große probleme mit ihnen gesetzen
ins spiel die fake news best
informationen und hassreden regulieren
wollen in den verfassungen der meisten
demokratischen länder ist das recht auf
freie meinungsäusserung fest verankert
und eines der am tiefsten verankerten
grundrechte ein grundpfeiler und garant
der demokratie natürlich erkennt alle
von ihnen bestimmte ausnahmen an zum
beispiel wenn es um die verletzung von
persönlichkeitsrechten geht also zum
beispiel beleidigungen aber in diesem
fall sprechen wir über ein viel tiefer
liegendes problem wir reden über die
möglichkeit inhalte aus gründen zu
zensieren die ganz einfach unglaublich
schwer zu definieren sind in den meisten
fällen sind sie ungeheuer subjektiv und
willkürlich innerhalb der europäischen
union gibt ist jedoch immer mehr die
eine politik der harten hand zur
eindämmung schädlicher inhalte fordern
und zum zeitpunkt der erstellung dieses
videos wird von der eu das gesetz über
digitale inhalte erarbeitet das
plattformen für die auf ihnen zu
ermöglichen inhalte verantwortlich macht
bisher handelt es sich nur um einen
vorschlag die debatte ist noch offen
viele kritiker auch politiker befürchten
jedoch dass dieses gesetz dazu dienen
wird bestimmte politischen positionen
wie skepsis gegenüber der eu oder kritik
an ihrer migrationspolitik zum schweigen
zu bringen rechtlich ist es eu-weit
durchaus schwierig online plattformen
für die tausende von stunden an videos
die sie husten und verantwortlich zu
machen dass zu schweigen davon wie
schwierig ist wäre dieses gesetz in die
verfassungen vieler mitgliedsstaaten
einzupassen es gibt also immer noch
keinen politischen konsens zu diesem
thema und deshalb hat das europäische
parlament im frühjahr 2021 eine studie
veröffentlicht mit dem titel die haftung
von online-plattformen das ist richtig
und damit ist die eu doktrin klar online
plattformen sind für die inhalte dieser
anzeigen verantwortlich und sie sollen
nicht nur handeln wenn es eine
urheberrechtsverletzung wird sondern
auch wenn es einen verstoß gegen den
öffentlichen anstand oder die moral gibt
diese studie schlägt vier verschiedene
szenarien vor nichtstun b die
bevölkerung durch medienpädagogische
kampagnen erziehen
öffentlich-private regulierung und die
selbstregulierung da haben wir es also
moment ist das gängigste szenarien
europa das sich die plattformen selbst
regulieren das heißt dass sie ein
regelwerk erstellen und sich darum
kümmern alle sogenannten schädlichen
inhalte zu löschen die sich
eingeschlichen haben könnten du hast
jetzt wahrscheinlich schon ganz stark wo
wir das problem liegt aber ich wette
dass du ziemlich überrascht sein wirst
dass wir ganz einfach mit einem kurzen
und sehr lehrreichen blick in die
geschichte zeigen können auf welche
weise das ganze ausarten kann und welche
gefahren uns konkret drohen also
aufgepasst
die unglückliche geburt des happy end
was wäre wenn ich dir sagen würde dass
hollywood happy end eine antwort auf die
damalige zensur war ja in der tat das
happy end wurde zu einer zeit erfunden
als film einfach nicht schlecht enden
durften zumindest nicht wenn sie das
gütesiegel erhalten wollten um in kinos
gezeigt zu werden ich gibt ein beispiel
mister smith goes to washington ist
instant von frank capra dieser film
erzählt die geschichte eines
idealistischen politikers der es mit
allen korrupten senatoren in washington
aufnehmen muss
theoretisch hat dies keine moralisch
anstößige thematik zu haben oder im
gegenteil da will jemand gegen
korruption und für die demokratie
kämpfen aber vergiss nicht dass dieser
film im jahr 1939 herauskamen und kritik
an der funktionsweise des politischen
systems der usa konnte damals leicht als
anti amerikanische kommunistische
propaganda gewertet werden denn zu
dieser zeit hatten filme moralische
werte zu vermitteln sie sollten das
fußvolk in die richtige richtung
erziehen es musste klar sein wer die
bösen sind und wer die guten die bösen
und mussten bestraft werden die gruppen
mussten gewinnen und die moral der
geschichte muss den standards des
öffentlichen anstands genügen kommt euch
das nicht irgendwie bekannt vor aber
warte wenn jetzt kommt der post will ist
denn wenn es eine sache gibt für welche
die vereinigten staaten bekannt sind
dann ist es doch das recht auf freie
meinungsäusserung dieses ist ganz klar
ein ersten zusatzartikel der verfassung
verankert und geht viel weiter als zum
beispiel in deutschland in den usa darf
man zb ungestraft den holocaust leugnen
und jetzt fragst du dich ganz zu recht
wie es dann möglich gewesen sein soll in
den usa die meinungsfreiheit gerade von
filmen auf diese art zu zensieren und
hier kommt der nächste block 2 ist man
definierte ganz einfach das kino keine
ausdrucksmittel ist ich weiß du wirst
denken dass ich verrückt geworden bin
aber genau das ist passiert sollte es
eines nicht wir sprechen vom anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts damals war das
kino ein relativ neues technisches
phänomen genau so wie es heute die
plattformen für internet inhalte
darstellen wollte deswegen lautete die
richterliche doktrin des obersten
gerichtshof der usa die er in seinem
endgültigen urteil im jahr 1915
verkündete
die darstellung bewegter bilder ist ein
reines geschäft und nicht als teil der
presse des landes oder als organ der
öffentlichen meinung im sinne der
meinungsfreiheit zu betrachten news film
corporation versys industrial convention
of ohio und 1915 so einfach geht das
verfassung und grundrechte umgangen
kinofilme wurden fortan nicht mehr als
verfassungsmäßiges ausdrucksmittel für
meinungen betrachtet aber warte ein
moment denn die geschichte endet hier
noch lange nicht hast du schon mal von
der nido bewegung gehört nun auch
hierbei müssen wir nur etwas in der
geschichte herumwühlen und
herauszufinden dass es nichts neues
unter der sonne gibt der hase weiß die
in der 1920 er jahre war ein comedian
namens roscoe fatty arbuckle
der sogenannte skandal war die perfekte
reißerische geschichte sex mord und
hollywood-stars der perfekte cocktail
und zeitungen zu verkaufen und du wirst
nie erraten welche medien mogul ist war
der das meiste aus dieser geschichte
heraus holte sie skrupellos das
missbrauchte um seine macht und seinen
reichtum zu vervielfachen nun okay
vielleicht wirst du es doch erraten ganz
genau es war william randolph hearst zu
dieser zeit besaß er bereits mehrere
zeitungen im ganzen land und hatte eine
brilliante idee er gab seinen
herausgebern und redakteuren eine ganz
klare agenda vor die hollywood
sexskandale von einem tag auf den
anderen und zum top gesprächsthema in
jeder bar und jedem barbershop amerikas
zu machen
das ganze land wurde quasi aus dem
nichts skandalisiert überall sprach man
über nichts anderes mehr als die
verdorbene moral der hollywoodstars und
inmitten dieser moralinsauren panik
beschlossen die bundesstaaten plötzlich
und sicher gar nicht zufällig mit der
gesetzlichen regulierung dieser
schlimmen missstände zu beginn eine
politik der harten hand musste her kommt
euch das auch nicht irgendwie aus der
gegenwart bekannt vor und da filme
damals ja praktischerweise nicht mehr
als ausdrucksmittel für meinungen
angesehen wurden konnten die
verschiedenen bundesstaaten der usa alle
arten von zensur gesetzen erlassen im
jahr 1921 hatten bereits in 37
bundesstaaten eine so strenge zensur
eingeführt als ob sie mit dem service
wetteifern wollten und das war der
zeitpunkt an dem hollywood beschloss zu
handeln und sich selbst zu regulieren
also schob die motion picture
association of america einen kodex der
guten sitten
aber wie stellt man einen kodex der
richtigen moral das ist ganz einfach wer
waren zu dieser zeit die grössten
experten öffentlichen anstand nun ganz
offensichtlich die priester so kann
hollywood darauf wiesen zu engagieren
william harrison hayes einen
perspektivischen priester und sie haben
dabei wahrlich keine kosten gescheut
mister race kam damals auf ein gehalt
von 100.000 dollar im jahr in heutigen
dollar sprechen wir von mehr als 15
millionen dollar jahresgehalt für dieses
unmoralische sümmchen kann man schon
eine ganz ordentliche morath erwarten
nicht wahr aber das war noch lange nicht
das ende der fahnenstange
zusätzlich stellte der mann ein ganzes
team ebenfalls hoch dotierter priester
ein um ihnen bei der erstellung des
kodex zu helfen ein code exzessen
fertigstellung jahre dauerte und er als
hays code bekannt geworden ist ein
zensur kodex mit detaillierten regeln
wie diese geistliche in ihrem charakter
als solche sollten nicht als
comicfiguren oder als bösewichte
verwendet werden auszug aus der motion
pictures production kommt ab 1934
mussten alle filme von einem priester
gericht abgesegnet werden um das
moralische gütesiegel zu erhalten und
achte auf ein detail wir reden hier über
etwas viel schlimmeres als zensur die
hollywood beschränkte sich nicht darauf
eine bestimmte szene zu eliminieren oder
dieses zu verbieten gesprächen heer von
selbstregulierung also von etwas das von
den produktionsfirmen selbst akzeptiert
wurde daher wird die zensur von anfang
an und fordert die ganze geschichte ihre
grundgedanken ihrer intention einfach
alles was ist zum beispiel die
romanverfilmung der falke mit humphrey
bogart gesehen wenn du das buch auf dem
es basiert liest du wirst du sehen dass
darin eine figur offen homosexuell
dargestellt wird hast du dich daran dass
literatur als verfassungsmäßiges medium
der kommunikation angesehen würde also
genossen romane die freiheit der
meinungsäußerung aber film dürfte der
saldo charakter weder offen homosexuell
noch gut sein also wurde er einfach zu
einem verweichlichten gentleman und
natürlich zum bösewicht umgeschrieben
[Musik]
von den 1930 jahren bis zu 160 jahren
christus hunderte solcher beispiele
finden möglicherweise hat der oberste
gerichtshof in den 60er jahren seine
doktrin geändert heute gelesen filme in
den vereinigten staaten die gleiche
meinungsfreiheit wie alle anderen medien
wir sprechen hier über mehr als 40 jahre
zensur eine komplette verlorene
generation die in ihren grundrechten
beschnitten war und durch ein kartell
ausgerechnet politiker an priestern und
medien manipuliert wurde so und nun die
rolle vorwärts in die gegenwart und in
die eu es scheint dass ich die gleiche
geschichte wenn einer anderen neuen
technologie und umgekehrten vorzeichen
wiederholt europäische kommission und
unternehmen kündigen verhaltenskodex
gegen illegale online hassreden an
europäische kommission 31 10 mai 2016
genau in diesem video wollen die horror
levys einfach kein ende nehmen aber
bevor du aus verzweiflung alle hoffnung
fahren lässt lass mich dir sagen dass
dieser entwurf im moment noch recht vage
ist dh im moment beziehen sich die
einzigen beschränkungen auf propaganda
terroristischer gruppen und klare
hassbotschaften die zur gewalt aufrufen
und bereits in fast allen ländern
sowieso verboten wurden das problem ist
jedoch dass dieser kodex aus dem jahr
2060 stammt geben sind uns jedoch im
jahr 2021 und das maß an sozialer
polarisierung ist nochmals exponentiell
die höhe geschnellt und europa spin
doctor niehues und hayes von heute
lechzen nach noch mehr einschränkungen
gegen noch mehr macht über die menschen
leitfaden zur stärkung des
verhaltenskodex für desinformation
europäische kommission
sechsundzwanzigster mal 2021 das große
problem dass europa jetzt lösen will ist
nicht mehr hassrede und aufwiegelung zur
gewalt sondern desinformationen das
heißt alle jenen fake news und
verschwörungstheorien die im zeitalter
des coa virus auf den sozialen
netzwerken kursieren es geht nicht mehr
nur darum gewalt zu verhindern sondern
zu bestimmen was gesagt werden da und
was nicht was genau die einstigen wahre
wahrheit ist und was lüge aber wer
definiert was wahr ist und was nicht
kann dies wirklich unvoreingenommen
beurteilt werden und es soll
ausgerechnet intransparente
internetplattformen mit ihrer
unüberschaubaren zahl an inhalten in der
lage sein die wahrheit selbst zu
regulieren nun darüber werden wir in
einem kommenden video hier auf diese art
politik sprechen und wir werden uns die
unterschiede zwischen diesen drei
protagonisten genauer ansehen der sie
auch von youtube dem sie auf und
facebook und dem von twitter und in der
zwischenzeit ist deine meinung gefragt
was denkst du wie können fake news im
internet gefiltert werden sollten wir
das wirklich tun wird die büchse der
zensur pandora welche die eu eröffnen
wird irgendwann wieder zu schließen sein
vielleicht nach einer weiteren
verlorenen bevormundeten generation
teile deine meinung bitte die ema mit
uns und auch mit allen anderen im
kommentarbereich ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video trotzdem gefallen hat fast
jahre gibt uns bitte einen like und
teilt es auch mit euren freunden mut und
bis bald
[Musik]